Michael Jordan if it wasn't confirmed
before and again documentaries are
incredibly biased they get you to
believe whatever the [ __ ] they want
gambling addict extraordinaire yeah I
mean like neck slit next-level gambling
out of teeth he's addicted to gambling
but to the point that he's so rich it's
never a problem you know what I mean yes
gambling addiction is a real problem
though and this is what he brings up
he's like he doesn't think he's an
addict cuz he's like my wife hasn't left
me I'm not in financial trouble never
been in financial trouble you know my
parents aren't having interventions of
me because he's so [ __ ] rich that he
doesn't bet that so he's like addicted
to it to the point where it doesn't
interfere with any of his day-to-day
money it is interesting because like
let's say you know some successful guy's
wife likes to buy bags and shoes and all
this candy enough arguably you could say
that they spend and lose way more money
on all those items yeah then or even if
they spend and lose the same amount of
money yeah
when you're buying a bag or shoes
there's no chance you're gonna win right
like yeah there's no shot whatsoever
that if you buy that bag all of a sudden
you're gonna get three more bags right
right yeah so it's just a loss it's just
an expense it brings that woman joy yeah
so you got a clue that part Jordan
gambling rings joy but yeah that's just
a hip yeah when your advisor bad are you
happy what's she buying I said with your
money if a girl let's say Venus Williams
or Serena Williams that got all the
money in the world if they want to just
buy a bunch of a frivolous [ __ ] with
their money that's cool and we allow
that yeah but when it comes to gambling
we don't and I assume it's because we've
seen the addiction side of gambling yeah
right and it's like yes Jordan was
probably a gambling addict maybe is
probably gambling addict but like you
said he had the money to float it yeah
and it's not a habit that affected his
play right maybe the effect it is like
marriage and home life but I I assumed
that he was so locked into sports that
like that also affected it
but it isn't it is a kind of interesting
thing gambling is like what define what
makes it bad is it when you lose your
house it's bad yeah it's just like
alcohol alcohol is bad because there's
alcoholics gambling is bad because
there's gambling addicts but Jordan is
this example of an alcoholic that can
function as a function and gambling
addict he's a functioning alcoholic
he's a functioning smoker guys smoking
cigars every [ __ ] day his last year
we noticed every oh you didn't see
episode every clip of him his last
season he's smoking a cigar yeah yeah
Dennis Rodman comes in hey can I have a
cigar camera crews in there hey this is
just me smoking a cigar hey I'm on the
golf course smoking a cigar what do you
think that is season I I think your
point was brought up in at what the
first episodes were it's like you're
dealing with so much pressure yeah
there's got to be some kind of release
and I think gambling is that I think
drinking is that I think smoking a cigar
is that being like Mike sucks a lot the
overall its net positive probably but
like there's a lot of [ __ ] about if it's
sucks it's constant pressure yeah and I
want to get to this later but he had the
line where he said I if I could do it
all again I wouldn't I don't know if I I
don't I wouldn't be a role model he said
either I don't know if I'd be a role
model or I wouldn't be a Roma Oh when
did he say that they must be said
[Applause]